[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الالاف يتظاهرون في تلبيب وفرقاطات فرنسيه
تتعرض للهجوم بالقرب من السواحل اليمنيه
والكيان يتوعد الاداره الامريكيه تبيع
القذائف لتل ابيب دون مراجعه الكونجرس
النتنياهو يستنج بالرئيس الروسي الامين
العام للامم المتحده يؤكد تمسكه بموقفه
بشان القطاع ودول اوروبيه تتدخل للمسانده
الغرب يجيد الخليفه الاكثر امانا للرئيس
الاوكراني المخابره الامريكيه بايدن يحرض
على حرب النوويه والحفاظ على الذات
الامريكيه يتطلب عوده ترامب الى الرئاسه
وماكرون يطالب بضم اوكرانيا للاتحاد
الاوروبي بينما تعارض هنغاريا بشده
تلبيب تطلب
النجده بمبدا واحد تتمسك الامم المتحده او
هكذا هو ما يتم الاعلان عنه هنا قال
الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو جوتش
ان سلطه المجلس الامن ومصداقيته تقوت لعدم
القدره على تنفيذ قرار وقف اطلاق النار
بالقطاع وذلك بعد الفيتو الامريكي مضيفا
انه لن يتخلى عن الدعوه لوقف اطلاق النار
لاسباب انسانيه ليخرج المتحدث باسم مجلس
الامن القومي جون كاربي ويصرح ان
المسؤولين العبريين قلصوا عمليتهم
العسكريه واضاف بان ذلك جاء بسبب المخاوف
التي اثارتها بلاده حول احتمال وقوع خسائر
كبيره في صفوف المدنيين لكن هيئه البث
العبريه اعلنت انه لا وقف لاطلاق النار في
القطاع قبل شهرين لننتقل الى اليمن حيث
اعلنت اركان الجيوش الفرنسيه ان الفرقاطه
الفرنسيه لانج دوك اسقطت مسيرتين في البحر
الاحمر اطلقت باتجاهها من سواحل اليمن
هناك نقلت اذاعه الجيش العبري عن مدير
ميناء ايلات قوله ان تهديدات الحوثيين
منعت وصول سفن تحمل 14000 مركبه منذ ال من
نوفمبر وهنا تجمع الالاف في مسيره وسط
تلابيب لمطالبه حكومه النتنياهو بالتفاوض
من اجل اطلاق سراح جميع الرهائن المتبقين
في القطاع من جهتها طلبت اسبانيا وبلجيكا
وايرلندا ومالطا الاتحاد الاوروبي بضروره
الدعوه
لهدني ياتي ذلك قبيل قمه مرتقبه لدول
التكتل الاسبوع المقبل على وقع استمرار
المعارك في القطاع وفشل مجلس الامن الدولي
في الاتفاق على قرار ينهي القتال بالعوده
الى واشنطن اعلن البنتاجون ان الاداره
الامريكيه استخدمت صلاحيات للطوارئ للسماح
ببيع قذائف دبابات لاسرائيل دون مراجعه
الكونغرس وتبلغ قيمه القذائف الامريكيه
اكثر من 106 ملايين دولار بينما عاد
النتنياهو ليعبر عن شكره للرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين على جهوده في انقاذ مواطن
عبري كان محتجزا في القطاع وطالبه بالضغط
على الصليب الاحمر لزياره الاسرى لدى
الفصائل في الميدان وفي الضفه الغربيه
تحديدا افادت وكاله وفا بان القوات
العبريه اقتحمت بلده عصير الشماليه ومخيم
عسكر في نابلوس مما ادى الى اندلاع
مواجهات في المنطقه اسفرت عن اصابه اثنين
بجروح واعتقلت اخرين وسط اطلاق نار مكثف
في محيط بعض المباني كذلك اقتحمت القوات
العبريه مدينه طوباس من الجهه الشرقيه هنا
عاد الناطق الملثم للفصائل ابو عبيده
ليصرح بان مقاتليهم تمكنوا من التدمير
الكلي او الجزئي لاكثر من 180 اليه عسكريه
في عره ايام واضاف ان العبريين فشلوا في
شمال القطاع وجنوبه و سيفشلون اكثر كلما
استمر هجومهم فيما اعلنت الفصائل عن مقتل
واصابه العشرات من الجنود العبريين في
تفجير عبوه برميليه كبيره مضاده للافراد
في منطقه المعري شمال شرق مدينه خان يونس
هذا وكان الجيش العبري قد اعلن اجلاء 600
جندي جريح في القطاع في الحدود اللبنانيه
اعلن قائد المنطقه الشماليه في الجيش
العبري اوري جوردين استعداد الجيش للتصدي
للقوات التابعه لمقاومه لبنان وشن هجوم
عسكري قوي عند
الضروره خيار زيلينسكي
الامن هل اصبح زيلينسكي غير مرغوب به ام
انها رغبه غربيه فقط لتكشف صحيفه اونتي
ديبلوماتيك الايطاليه ان الخليفه الاكثر
امانا للرئيس الاوكراني الحالي فلاديمير
زيلينسكي والذي لن يعرض حياه الاخير
السياسيه للخطر في حال توليه للسلطه قد
يكون ترشيح رئيس مكتبه اندريه ارماك
للانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله مشيره الى ان
هذا سيوفر الى الرئيس الحالي خيارا اكثر
ليونه لنقل السلطه وربما توفر الانتخابات
فرصه متميزه وممتازه لمثل هذا التغيير
بينما افادت وكاله فرانس بريس بان الرئيس
الفرنسي امانويل ماكرون اكد خلال محادثه
هاتفيه مع زيلنسكي ان فرنسا مع بدء
المفاوضات بشان انضمام اوكرانيا الى
الاتحاد الاوروبي الامر الذي عارضه رئيس
الوزراء المجري بسبب الفساد الشديد
للحكومه الاوكرانيه هنا قال ضابط
المخابرات العسكريه الامريكي المتقاعد
سكوت ريتر ان سياسه الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن تحرض على اثاره مواجهه نوويه مع
روسيا واشار الى ان اوروبا تخشى اعاده
انتخاب دونالد ترامب رئيسا للولايات
المتحده لانه قد يحل حلف الناتو واضاف لكن
الحفاظ على الذات الامريكيه يتطلب عوده
ترامب لل رئاسه ليصرح الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين ان الغرب يسعى بشتى سبل
ويحاول جاهدا لضغط روسيا وتحجيمها
وايذائهم الا انه لن ينجح في ذلك ابدا
ميدانيا ذكرت صحيفه ميليتري واتش
الامريكيه ان القوات الامريكيه تحاول
تجنيد مرتزقه اجانب بسبب الخسائر الفادحه
في صفوف الافراد وتسبب ذلك بطمه كبيره في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه مضيفه ان معدل
القتل للجيش الاك على الخطوط الاماميه يصل
الى 80 الى 90% بين الوحدات المرسله الى
الجبهه فيما اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
في تقريرها اليومي ان القوات المسلحه
الروسيه قصفت اللواءين 102
و128 الاوكرانيين واحبطت هجوما من قبل
قوات كياب في جنوب دونيتسك واضافت الوزاره
الروسيه في حصيلتها اليوميه انها قضت على
اكثر من 570 عسكريا اوكرانيا واسقاط 20
مسيره اوكرانيه على مختلف
[موسيقى]
المحاور